oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah Assam oh yeah
Mary we're doing news today Australia's
hungover what drunken Ozzy's all right
it's Wednesday it's Thursday october
twenty second I'm Earl and this is
gamespot news first up a rock band for
developer admitted to having employees
of positive reviews to increase the star
scoring system on Amazon now in a
statement to Destructoid harmonics said
that it is clarified its internal policy
about posting reviews of our own
products on retail sites and we've asked
that existing reviews be edited to
identify harmonics employees or be
removed entirely harmonics went on to
say but it never intended to deceive the
game was already getting mostly positive
reviews anyway but still labeled the
actions inappropriate while we believe
the reviews posted by a few employees
were sincere and without ill intentions
as a studio we don't believe these are
appropriate actions we appreciate the
feedback from the community and take our
relationship with our fans seriously
rock band 4 launched in october six for
xbox one and ps4 game spa gave the game
a 7 out of 10 which would be three and a
half stars on amazon next up if you've
been playing street fighter 5 s second
open beta you've probably noticed that
you're also playing the waiting game
like its first beta in july street
fighter 5 s just launched second public
testing period is running into
submission
is in a blog post Capcom said
matchmaking issues cropped up
immediately after the beta went live
unfortunately several new issues arose
last night in regards to our matchmaking
system and the rate at which matches
were made Capcom said we are not
confident that the matchmaking rate will
improve significantly through the course
of this beta period that said user
experiences will vary Capcom admitted
though that the beta will be limited and
will not operate exactly as intended you
can check out the complete Street
Fighter 5 beta schedule on gamespot and
note that the only way to get in is to
pre-order the game the Halo series is
huge but it's not as massive as another
franchise but not if the boss at 343
industries has anything to say about it
Bonnie Ross head of Halo developer 343
Industries has revealed some interesting
new insight into Microsoft's blockbuster
sci-fi shooter series it might surprise
you to learn that when she helped create
343 industries in 2009 not everyone
inside Microsoft bought halo would be
around much longer people felt like
let's get another Halo or two out and
it's the end of the franchise Ross
recalled in a new interview with Hubert
business when discussing the future Halo
series and what she wanted to do as
three four threes general manager Ross
said she asked to be granted George
Lucas like control over the franchise
Lucas created the star wars franchise
and oversaw it until he eventually sold
the series to Disney in 2012 for 4.05
billions the thing i asked for was I
take over I want to be George Lucas she
said I want to own everything and I
do things differently in a previous
interview Ross said Microsoft's hope is
for the Halo franchise to remain popular
for at least another 30 years the next
release from 343 is halo 5 guardians
which launches on october 27th for xbox
one beautiful and that's all the news we
have for you today go out there and play
a game don't you know the witcher 3 pack
came out today i hate you so much but
with it only I didn't love you